[موسيقى]
قد يبدو أي تغيير على أنه مخاطرة صغيرة ،
لكن عندما تكدسهم جميعًا
فوق بعضهم البعض ، يبدو الأمر كرجل مثل
برج جينغا ، ستسحب كل الأحجار في الأسفل وإلا ستفشل
[موسيقى]
يشير الرئيس التنفيذي لفحم الكوك في برج جينجا جيمس كوينسي
إلى أن إمبراطورية كوكا كولا بأكملها
تتألف من 400 علامة تجارية في
أكتوبر من العام الماضي أعلن كوينسي أنه
كان يقتل نصف محفظة الشركة ،
أعطني علامة تبويب
لا يمكنني إعطائك جهازًا لوحيًا لك  اطلب
شيئًا
ولم يكن الجميع سعداء به ، كان الأمر
كما لو كنت عندما تم
إطلاق النار على كينيدي ، ولن أنسى أبدًا مكان تواجدي عندما
اتصل شخص ما وقال إنك لن
تكون قادرًا على الحصول على علامة التبويب بعد الآن
، كما يقول إن بعض الأشخاص قد أقاموا جنازات
بالنسبة للعلامات التجارية ، لذلك إذا كنت بحاجة إلى أي علامة تبويب
فنية للحزن على فقدان علامة التبويب ،
فأنت فقط ستقدم لك بعض
الأشياء الرائعة
بشكل جيد ، لقد تلقيت الكثير من التعليقات
من بعض المستهلكين الذين شعروا
بخيبة أمل كبيرة لأننا كنا نغيب
البعض  من العلامات التجارية ولذا نعم كان الأمر
جيدًا  يصعب
على بعض المستهلكين الانتقال من هذه
العلامات التجارية ، ونأمل أن نوفر لهم
علامات تجارية أخرى للذهاب إليها وعدد العلامات التجارية التي تم
التخلص من الكوكا كولا خلال فترة عملك كرئيس
تنفيذي بحلول نهاية
العام المقبل ، أعتقد أننا سنكون كذلك  في حوالي 200.
سيكون هذا ما يقرب من نصف العلامات التجارية
التي امتلكناها ، ولكن كان
هناك فرق كبير جدًا
بين أسرع
العلامات التجارية مبيعًا وأكبر العلامات التجارية والمنتجات
وبعض العلامات التجارية البطيئة  مجرد
احتلال مساحة مثل
تجاعيد الشرايين إذا كنت ترغب في ذلك ولذا
عليك تنظيفها على
الرغم من رد الفعل ، قال كوينسي إن
القرار لم يكن صعبًا بشكل خاص ،
فأنا مهندس في القلب
وعقلاني وسيكون من العدل أن  قل في
وقت مبكر من مسيرتي المهنية عندما
بدأت الشركة في دفع
المزيد من الجهد نحو الابتكار ،
تتعلم الدرس أنه بغض النظر عن
مدى قربك من العلامة التجارية
، يجب أن تكون على استعداد
لجعل الحصص الغذائية  القرار
لصالح المحفظة الأكبر حجمًا ، فمن بين 200
علامة تجارية طلبتها كان
من المفهوم تاريخيًا أنه لا يمكن
لمسها عند توليك منصب مدير تنفيذي مثل لا
لا لا ، سيستمر هذا على
الرغم من أنه قد لا يكون كذلك  الورق منطقي ،
نعم ، أعني أن العديد من تلك العلامات التجارية
قد حاول الرؤساء التنفيذيون السابقون إلغاءها أيضًا وإخراجها من مكانها
، فهناك
ميل في المنظمة للتوجه
نحو
الأفضل ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي فعلنا بها ذلك دائمًا ، فنحن ناجحون جدًا ،
وبالتالي  على الرغم من أنني لست متأكدًا من
الدور الذي تلعبه هذه العلامة التجارية ، إلا أنه يجب أن يكون جزءًا
من صيغة النجاح الشاملة ، لذا
فإن القدرة على التراجع
والتفصيل والقول نعم لقد حققنا
نجاحًا كبيرًا وهذا لا يعني كل ما
نقوم به جميعًا  الوقت هو الأفضل على مستوى
عالمي هو شيء يجب أن نحتفظ به
في المستقبل ، لكنني رأيت فرصتي هذه
المرة
أن الفرصة كانت الوباء العالمي
بمجرد أن كان لدى فحم الكوك إطارًا للتعامل مع
الأزمة الفورية التي كان يعلم أنه يجب أن
يفعلها  NK أكبر ، أكبر خطر أعتقد أنه
كان ركوب تلك اللحظة الوبائية في
الربع الثاني من عام 2020 مباشرة في
أبريل ، فربما أعني أن العالم كان ينتهي ،
لقد كانت الأحجام تنخفض ، كما تعلمون ، كان هناك
رقم مزدوج في Coca-Cola ، كل شيء كان
مغلقًا
في سلسلة التوريد كان مسدودًا  في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، ما الذي سنفعله في
الواقع توقفنا عن محاولة إدارته
يومًا بعد يوم وبدأنا التركيز على حسنًا
، ستنتهي هذه الأزمة وعندما
تنتهي هذه الأزمة ،
هل نريد أن نكون معروفين بمجرد
إدارتنا للأزمة
أو  هل نريد أن نكون معروفين بأننا
خرجنا أقوى وأن نكون مستعدين لتحقيق
المزيد من النمو عندما تنتهي الأزمة
وهو كيف توصلنا إلى أه
للقرارات المتعلقة بقص المحفظة
وتغيير الطريقة التي نعمل بها
كمنظمة تغيير التركيز على ما
نحن نستثمر فيها لأننا انتقلنا فورًا على
الفور تقريبًا خلال
الأزمة إلى التركيز على المستقبل حول
كيفية الاستعداد لعام 2022.
راند يجب أن نتوقع الآن
موجة مد وجزر من المنتجات الجديدة منتجات كوكا كولا
أه ضرب الأرفف
كما تعلم بطريقة نعم بطريقة ما ، انظر إلى الأمر على هذا النحو ،
لقد انتهزنا
الفرصة لسحب النصف الأضعف من
المحفظة والآن  أن العالم يعيد فتح
الناس يريدون الخروج للتجربة الاجتماعية ،
ابحث عن أشياء جديدة
وفرص جديدة الآن هو الوقت المناسب
لابتكار ابتكارات جديدة
ومنتجات جديدة ، وعلى الرغم من أن كوينسي يقول
إنه يشعر بالأسف لأن توقف هذه
العلامات التجارية قد تنفست حياة جديدة في
رغبة الشركة في التجريب ،
أعتقد أن هذا منح
المنظمة مزيدًا من الاعتقاد بأنه
يمكن المخاطرة فعليًا ، أعني أننا نميل
إلى البحث عن الأشياء
ونتردد لأنه كان من الممكن أن يحدث خطأ ما ،
فقد نسينا فكرة أن شيئًا ما
يمكن أن يسير على ما يرام نحن البشر  تمت
برمجتها لزيادة الوزن إلى حد بعيد
الأشياء التي نخسرها مقابل الأشياء التي قد
نكتسبها للمخاطرة والابتكار هو
عدم السماح للخوف مما أنت ذاهب
لتخسر احتمالية ما
قد تكسبه